Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Euler seid ihr so schnell am Start hier!
Excellent
High IQ Mode
Activated
Ich muss jetzt den Song erstmal 80 mal in Schleife hören
Dass ich ready für C++ bin
Achso, oben rechts hier, ne
Habt ihr, wie wir das Projekt das letzte Mal verlassen haben
Das ist auch ein Live-Bild.
Das ist nicht einfach nur so.
Warte mal, ich mach mal die Hand davon.
Dann seht ihr es hier.
Achtung.
Hä?
Warum sieht man meinen...
Haha.
Fake.
Ah ne, jetzt hat man es gesehen.
Ja, Fingerleak.
Black Ops 7.
Ey.
Das interessiert mich so überhaupt nicht mehr.
Ich habe die letzten Call of Duty-Skills im Multiplayer kaum gespielt, weil es mich einfach immer nur abgefuckt hat, wenn ich mir diese halbherzigen Produkte angeguckt habe.
Oh, ne.
Die haben mich komplett verloren seit ein paar Jahren.
Aber komplett.
Kannst du kurz zeigen, was los ist?
Guck da oben rechts, da siehst du es.
Ich habe einen ESP32T Display S3.
in die ESP32S3T-Display.
Simon, Moment.
Moment, wir müssen erstmal die Musik changen.
Vor allem changen.
Wir changen jetzt die Musik, Leute.
Wir können die nicht einfach umwechseln
oder so.
Wir haben gechanged.
Meine Lieblings-Playlist.
So, also hier, guck.
Wir haben...
dieses board hier dieses board haben wir nicht das ist das alte ist da dieses
bot zaubert das richtige alter das ist das richtige dieses board hier das hat
ein 170 x 320 lcd display mit also mit viel farben nicht einfach nur so diese
billig farben die viele andere microcontroller displays haben sondern man sieht hier oben also
das sieht richtig richtig gut aus die farben darauf das ist jetzt ein bisschen komisch aussieht liegt
daran dass ich das handy drüber liegen habe und dann noch die lampe an und sowas aber wenn man
sich das also wenn ich mir das jahr und sie das richtig gut aus und das ziel ist folgendes das
ziel ist das ziel ist dort ein bisschen text darauf anzuzeigen nämlich eine wlan ssd zum
beispiel und ein qr code und wenn man den qr code dann scannt dann kommt man automatisch in den ex
also im handy zum beispiel in den access point den der esp aufmacht und wenn man dann in dem
Access Point drin ist, kann man
auf der Webseite und seine
WLAN Credentials eingeben, über
HTTPS und das ist eigentlich nie
unverschlüsselt. Und das ist halt easy, weil du kannst
den QR-Code vom Display scannen und kannst direkt
das Setup weiter
durchführen von dem Ding.
Eigentlich ist es aber nicht so,
dass ich jetzt irgendwie großartig
was vorhabe damit oder irgendwas
in der Richtung. Ich will einfach nur mal ausprobieren,
wie man das macht.
Das ist jetzt nicht, dass ich unbedingt was
wirklich
ja,
production ready damit bauen will oder so.
Hast du auch Gehäuse wie?
Ja, ich kann es euch nicht zeigen.
Wobei doch, ich kann es euch zeigen. Ich glaube, das haben die hier auch
auf dem
Bin mir gar nicht sicher, welche ich habe.
Ich habe hier nur noch die, Moment.
Ich habe hier nur noch die
die Box
Guckt.
die box habe ich noch falls man das hier gerade sieht man kann das nicht richtig
darin erkennen er macht ja nichts ich habe mir aber auch zwei stück bestellt
mit diesem case dabei weil ich das ganz nice fand und die china chinesen die
sind auch immer schön schön günstig weil da kriegst du für 13 dollar kompletten
micro controller das ist also der hat wirklich power das ding so ist es nicht
das hat ein du das ding hat hier dieses kleine teil da also eigentlich ist das
hier ja das hier ist ja der eigentliche chip nur der rest ist ja eigentlich der
rest ist nur bonus drumherum wie sagt der kleine chip das ist ein esp 32 s 3
der hat ein dual core 2,4 gigahertz wer vielleicht jetzt dort doch ein bisschen
viel 240 megahertz dual core 240 megahertz und 8 mb ram also das ist
richtig das richtig power hat das ding 6 16 mb flash 8 mb ram wifi bluetooth und halten dual
core 240 megahertz prozessor also das ding hat schon ganz ordentlich power das zusammen mit dem
gehör also und dass das board hat auch batterienanschlüsse usb anschlüsse alles was man
so braucht und im endeffekt kriegst halt hier schöne kombi aus aus case recht starke micro
controller mit schönem display und da hast du auch noch ein paar gps wenn du
sensoren und so dran anschließen will ich finde es ist echt gut kombination
meint und mal ohne scheiß für 13 dollar wenn ihr das wahrscheinlich bei
aliexpress kaufs gucken wir mal wenn er das wahrscheinlich bei aliexpress kauft
ist wahrscheinlich sogar noch ein ticken billiger
alter aliexpress jetzt übertreibt halt mit pop ups wie viel wie viele pop ups
wollen wir noch auf einmal machen
aliexpress ist teuer geworden ist das so
das ist die welt das ist so ein typisches aliexpress debate angebot
wenn du dich dann einloggt und es hier an klickst dann ist es entweder nur usb
kabel oder das klappt am endeffekt nicht das ist das ist das hat hat kochi bait
typisches aliexpress gebet angebot ja aber anscheinend ist es gibt es
tatsächlich doch gar nicht so viel günstiger bei aliexpress aliexpress ist
da also muss ganz ehrlich sagen also was so die übersicht angeht ist ich meine
wenn wenn wir jetzt nicht wüssten chat wenn wir nicht wüssten dass es
aliexpress ist und ich da schon paar mal bestellt hätte und auch ich nie probleme
Wenn ihr diese Seite aufmacht
Das habe ich glaube ich schon ein paar mal gefragt
Wenn ihr diese Seite aufmacht, würdet ihr denken
Legit oder Scam
Ich glaube 90% der Leute würden denken
Alter was ist eine Scam Seite, guckt euch das Ding mal an
Wie das ausschaut
Das sieht so was von
Das sieht so was von einer Scam aus
Du würdest sofort denken, Scam
Ja Bang
Witzigerweise Banggood sieht halt genauso aus
Die Seite
Sieht auch aus wie Scam
Es hat alles das chinesische Ministerium für Webdesign erstellt.
Alles genau in der gleichen Stadt.
Guckt es euch an.
Sieht genauso aus.
Die H-Gate gibt es ja auch noch.
Hier.
Sieht halt aus.
Das ist ganz genau das gleiche.
Chinesische Ministerium für Webdesign hat zugeschlagen.
So, wir müssen uns jetzt erstmal in das passende High-Performer-C++-Mindset begeben, Leute.
Wie ist das? Was erzählen die immer?
Du kannst alles erreichen. Und wie war das?
kannst du nicht, dann helfen wir dir
und willst du nicht, dann ist dir nicht mehr
zu helfen. Genau.
High Performer
Mindset muss ausgepackt werden.
Ich finde diese Sprüche immer so
cringe.
Was da irgendwelche Vertriebler
ablassen in der Richtung.
Ich kann es immer noch nicht verstehen, dass es immer noch Leute gibt,
die da drauf reinfallen.
Mal kurz meine Tastatur abstöpseln.
Ja.
Quality is Destiny. Genau. Ist auch so
ein Ding, Alter.
Quality is Destiny.
Das waren die im Lager
von Amazon, ne?
Das waren die aus dem
Amazon-Lager. Ja.
Quality is Destiny.
Ah, ich weiß nicht.
Es gibt so viele blöde Sprüche in der Richtung.
Oh, wir müssen erstmal Package-Updates machen.
Und dann Reboot.
Natürlich, Arch by the way.
Das System ist eindeutig nicht Bleeding Edge genug, wenn ich nicht alle Viertelstunde mal update.
Oder alle Viertelstunde updaten kann.
Mach mal diesen blöden Witz mit High-Performer-Cry-Incept-Mindset raus.
Und vor allem warum ist da warum ist da ein Emoji mit
Reißverschluss macht ja auch keinen Sinn da muss das Raketen Emoji hin
wir sind so Agile
Chat bevor wir anfangen habe ich ja ganz vergessen wir sind doch so agil eigentlich müssen wir erstmal Sprint Planning machen
Oder zumindest zumindest wenn wir schon keine Sprint Planung machen für heute Chat dann wenigstens Daily Stand Up
Daily Scrum auf...
Warte mal jetzt.
Mein Daily Scrum besteht aus Reboot.
Warum haue ich eigentlich gerade so auf meine Enter-Taste drauf?
Die kann ja überhaupt nichts.
Nichts dafür, dass ich jetzt C++ programmieren muss.
Das ist wirklich die schlimmste Sprache überhaupt.
Okay, das kann man nicht sagen. Es gibt Sprachen, die sind absichtlich gemacht, um scheiße zu sein.
Ja, so Brainfuck oder sowas.
Es ist nicht die schlimmste Sprache überhaupt.
Aber es ist die schlimmste Sprache, die versucht gut zu sein.
Also die nicht versucht von Haus aus irgendwie zu trollen oder so.
Die wirklich versucht gut zu sein.
C++ Schrott, Alter.
Aber kommen wir nicht drum herum.
So, machen wir C-Line auf.
mit einer gescheiten idee ist es zumindest schon ein bisschen erträglicher aber auch nur ein
bisschen auch nur ein bisschen nicht viel so jetzt haben wir hier unser projekt ich zeige das gleiche
es ist bei way das ist das ist alles also mehr mehr gibt es da nicht ich kann das auch gleich
zeigen die hälfte davon können wir wahrscheinlich gleich wegschmeißen heute verwenden wir wahrscheinlich
auch lvgl um da text drauf zu malen oder vielleicht auch irgendwie noch mal ein button oder sowas auf
Das Display-Unhalt in QR-Code.
Was wollte ich jetzt noch machen?
Chatge, irgendwas wollte ich jetzt noch machen.
Ich hab's voll vergessen.
Ich hab's, glaube ich, auch nicht gesagt.
Ich hatte das nur im Hinterkopf, aber
jetzt komplett verdrängt.
Außer ein bisschen C++-Rant.
Aber das kommt ja automatisch.
Daily Sprint wollten wir machen, genau.
Daily Scrum.
Ja was sind eure pläne für heute chat daily stand up habt ihr irgendwelche blocker
Alles wochen um 16 uhr neue protz system zu deployen finde ich auch finde ich auch
Ja.
Ich musste heute übrigens nicht arbeiten.
Ich habe heute frei.
Ich musste heute zum Fäden ziehen.
Aber nichts Schlimmes.
Mir hat der Hautarzt so ein Leberfleck rausgemacht.
Der war das letzte Mal bei der Kontrolle noch ganz okay.
Also, was heißt ganz okay?
Nichts Auffälliges.
Und diesmal hat er gemeint, ja, vielleicht nicht verkehrt, wenn man rausmacht.
Okay.
Es juckt, juckt immer noch.
Ich habe zwei Stellen.
Du musst noch T-Shirt Size festlegen.
Ja, bei uns gibt es nur XXL.
XXL Aufwände.
Anderes haben wir nicht.
Hippo Fat Size.
Was ich da mache? Aktuell mache ich noch gar nichts.
Was wir jetzt machen werden ist, auf diesem Microcontroller, den ihr hier oben rechts seht, anstatt darauf anzuzeigen, versuchen wir jetzt da gleich drauf Text anzuzeigen und einen QR-Code.
Einen QR-Code, den man scannen kann mit dem Handy und dann drinnen steht, welches WLAN man sich connecten muss.
Was genau meinst du?
Was ist mit der Katz?
Was gab es heute zu essen?
Heute habe ich mir Pizza geholt
Sardellenpizza
Mag noch jemand Sardellenpizza?
Viele Leute cringen dann immer so
Wenn ich sage ich mag Sardellenpizza
Sagen alle
Wie kann man sowas essen?
Voll abartig
Ich mag Sardellenpizza
Sardellenpizza ist so schön salzig
Das ist cringe
Ja, naja
Aber nicht so schlimm wie Ananaspizza, oder?
Oh, ist ja verpönt.
Carbon, ja, geht auch.
Kann man, kann man, weiß ich nicht, habe ich glaube ich noch nie zusammen gegessen.
Stelle ich mir aber vor, passt auch ganz gut zusammen.
Ja, also ich zeige jetzt mal ganz kurz, was wir gemacht haben das letzte Mal.
Das ist wirklich nicht viel und die Hälfte davon schmeißen wir wahrscheinlich auch gleich weg.
Also ich habe mir rausgesucht, wie das Display am Microcontroller angeschlossen ist.
Also erstmal haben wir hier oben die Größe vom Display, ja, das ist 170 Pixel breit, 320 Pixel hoch.
Dann habe ich die Pins rausgesucht, wo das Display angeschlossen ist.
Wie man sowas rauskriegt, ist ganz einfach.
Man geht hier hin und geht auf das Datenblatt vom Hersteller.
Oder, was noch besser ist, wenn der Hersteller einfach ein Bild hat, an welchen GPIOs was dran ist.
So, da habe ich mir das rausgesucht.
By the way, ich wollte das eigentlich gucken.
Ich will das...
Naja, gut, was auch immer ihr erkennt.
Hier sieht man, an welchen Pins das Display angeschlossen ist.
weil letztendlich hat der esp 32 s3 ja ganz ganz viele gp möglichkeiten das was hier raus geführt
wird auf das board sind ja nur ein paar davon und parken halt auch direkt an das display so
und da haben wir uns erstmal angeguckt an welchen gps ist das display dran also was ist hier die
der Glock ist das glaube ich Glock Pin weiß ich gar nicht was DC ist.
Right Read Power Pin zum Display einschalten Backlight Pin um die Hintergrundbeleuchtung
vom Display einzuschalten das würde man nicht sehen ja ein LCD ohne Hintergrundbeleuchtung
funktioniert aber sieht nichts und dann hier irgendwie noch die Pins für Datenübertragung
an das display aus irgendwelchen gründen haben wir das zweimal definiert was irgendwie keinen
sinn macht deswegen schmeißen wir das wieder raus so und was wir dann machen ist eins zu eins aus
dem beispiel mister 2003 wollen wir schalten die den strom an fürs display wir setzen das hier auf
auf 1, weil ich habe keine Ahnung warum, das steht im Beispiel drin und ohne könnte sein, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Dann legen wir hier irgendwelche Magic Sachen an, die habe ich auch aus dem Beispiel.
Da muss man zum Beispiel angeben, welche Pins für DC, welche Pins für Right, das habe ich alles aus dem Beispiel kopiert.
Und welche Pins für die Datenübertragung ans Display notwendig sind.
Höhe mal Breite mal Farbtiefe dürfen übertragen werden gleichzeitig an Bytes.
und dann muss man ein paar andere sachen einstellen wie mit welcher busfrequenz
bus taktfrequenz das ganze angesprochen wird und ja das hier war wichtig
colorswap bytes sonst ist grün und rot vertauscht warum wissen auch nur die
china chinesen die das ding gebaut haben
wir benutzen RGB für unsere Pixelinfos, für unsere Pixelfarben, nicht BGR, sondern RGB, also ganz klassische Sache,
streng genommen ist es RGB 565, habe ich mir sagen lassen, steht auch glaube ich hier irgendwie da,
so, dann resetten wir einmal das Display beim Start vom Controller, initialisieren das Display,
sagen, er soll die Farben invertieren, sonst muss man machen, sonst stimmen die Farben einfach nicht,
Das habe ich alles, wie gesagt, aus dem offiziellen Beispiel.
Dann swappen wir X und Y.
Und mirren X.
Das liegt daran, weil ich das Ding nicht hoch kann, sondern schräg betreiben will.
Dann müssen wir irgendeinen Gap setzen, dass es stimmt, wo er anfängt, auf dem Display zu malen.
Und dann schalten wir das Display an.
Die Funktion ist auch irgendwie ziemlich beknackt benannt.
es gibt eine funktion display on off und dann über gibst du on off als bull warum gibt es
nicht eine funktion display on und display off also auf mit bull ist irgendwie so weiß ich gibt
schon das ja zumal es gibt eine display off funktion aber keine display on funktion sondern
dann schalten wir die Hintergrundbeleuchtung ein.
Jo, und dann,
das ist schwarz,
alle Bytes auf 0,
dann malen wir einen schwarzen Hintergrund
beim Starten vom Microcontroller
von links oben
nach rechts unten auf dem Display,
also quasi von Koordinaten 0,0,
0,0 ist links oben,
und dann halt 320 Pixel
breit und 170 Pixel hoch.
So, Display,
dass der Hintergrund schwarz ist,
Und dann malen wir ein Bitmap drauf.
Und dieses Bitmap haben wir mit FFM-Pack erzeugt.
Das heißt ein OLED-Display.
Ich glaube schon.
Es gibt dieses Ding zumindest mit OLED-Display.
Ach, Burn-In juckt mich nicht.
Und dann malen wir ein Bild drauf.
und das Bild
ist einfach das hier
einfach das hier
mit FFmpeg konvertiert
in ein Bitmap und dann
konvertiert in ein Bitmap
mit
RGB 565
Color
Space
keine ahnung es hat einfach ein pack gemacht aber es funktioniert und dann haben wir dieses bild was
einfach ein pack rausgekommen ist einfach hier in den in den c style array umwandeln dass das
ist das bild hier und das bild wird dann auf display gemalt bis sonst passiert nichts das
heißt wir haben da noch kein qr code oder sonst irgendwas in der richtung auf dem display
Wenn ihr das letzte Mal verpasst habt, ist auch nicht schlimm, weil das meiste davon
schmeißen wir heute wieder weg.
Wir gucken uns jetzt erstmal an, wie man einen QR-Code malt.
Ich habe einen interessanten Blogartikel gefunden dazu.
Mal kurz.
Hier habe ich mir gemerkt.
Der hat nämlich ein schönes Beispiel, wie man ein QR-Code malt mit dem eingebauten...
Also vom Hersteller, die liefern quasi schon für den Controller eine Library für QR-Code-Generierung mit.
Und das probieren wir jetzt einfach mal, würde ich sagen.
Weil ich meine, wir haben erstmal alles da, was wir brauchen.
Wir brauchen auch noch nicht LVGL oder sonst was für.
Wir malen mal wirklich einfach RAW Pixel auf das Display.
So, dazu werden wir erstmal hier dieses Bild wieder weg machen.
Set Color, schwarzer Hintergrund ist schon mal ganz sinnvoll, dass man überhaupt was ordentlich sieht.
So, und jetzt überlegen wir uns mal, wie wir den QR-Code generieren.
Dazu brauchen wir erstmal diese QR-Code.
FFmpeg ist das beste.
Dazu brauchen wir erstmal die Library für QR-Codes.
Zack.
Repos, wie heisst das Ding nochmal?
QR-Code Champ.
So, installieren wir die Library für QR-Codes und dann können wir loslegen.
Ich bilde noch mal kurz
Dass er das auch checkt
So
Dann schauen wir doch mal
Ja, Bild finished
Also, wie funzt das?
Der hat irgendwie ein anderes Display wie ich
Deswegen ist das schon mal egal
Hier ist irgendwie
Die Daten für den QR-Code
Wir schreiben in den QR-Code einfach
Omega Lull rein
zum Testen.
Da macht er sein Display gedünst. Das ist egal.
Das sieht bei unserem Display komplett anders aus.
Display
Provisioning Screen. Aha.
Hier malt er den
QR-Code, würde ich sagen.
Hä? Ja.
Und wo generiert er den QR-Code?
Hier.
ESP
QR-Code generate.
alles klar ob das ist das was wir brauchen esp qr code generate den rest hier oben den
können wir einfach mal komplett vergessen der ist jetzt vom letzten mal auch da und
da machen wir nichts dran oder vielleicht schmeißen was raus wahrscheinlich schmeißt
man die hälfte hier von nachher wieder raus vermutlich also nicht so was ist das denn
ein display funk
payload
ach hier kommt der text für den qr code rein ja gut text ist omega 0
jetzt brauchen wir eine display ein display funk also irgendein callback
machen wir mal hässliche
C++ Lambda Syntax.
So, FMT,
Printline,
äh, Progu,
keine Ahnung, irgendwas. Ach ne,
wir können ja den QR-Code mal printen lassen
auf der Konsole. Also hier auf
die Debug-Konsole raus.
Schauen wir mal.
Guck mal, was passiert.
Ich flash das jetzt einfach mal.
weil ihr das tut ich würde sagen das sieht eigentlich ganz easy aus das wird wahrscheinlich
gehen da ist ein qr code hat jemand zufällig war jetzt gerade ein handy da und kann gucken
ob das ein qr code ist in dem omega lull drin steht aber hat windows hat windows nicht
mittlerweile auch so ein QR-Code-Scanner.
Äh, Screenshot.
Snipping, Snipping-Tool.
Hier, QR-Code.
Omega-Lul.
Okay.
Hier ist Omega-Lul drin encoded.
Wir wollen das natürlich nicht auf dem,
nicht auf dem Terminal anzeigen lassen,
sondern hier oben rechts auf dem Display
vom ESP.
Das heißt, oh, jetzt müssen wir,
Moment, wie macht denn der Dude hier das?
Size?
Okay.
Ich klau mir das jetzt von dem einfach.
Reformat. Ich klau mir das jetzt einfach.
Mal gucken. Also Display.
Phil reckt.
start sei es ja ich denke mal das müsste einfach so funktionieren
rekt xy sei es ein pixel
also data brauchen wir noch
moment bitte kein data brauchen im moment
etwas mache ich denn hier so falsch wir können doch hier unsere unsere set color
funktion von null bis null ein pixel mal ein pixel und jetzt muss eine farbe
übergeben das hier ist schwarz also 0
genau so und jetzt das nicht 000 xy das mache ich das gibt ja gar keinen sinn
hier und das hier unten noch mal das gleiche im endeffekt nur dass wir als
farbe weiß machen so wenn das jetzt von uns haben wir das gleiche qr code auf dem display
ich glaube ja nicht dass das geht ehrlich gesagt wobei doch klein set mindset wird bestimmt
funktionieren.
Da tut sich irgendwas.
Chat. Chat.
Da.
Irgendwas.
Irgendwas passiert da gerade.
Guck mal.
Es lädt den QR-Code.
Das ist aber ganz schön langsam.
Es ist ganz schön langsam und es dürfte durchaus ein bisschen größer sein.
Ja.
Klein und langsam ist es.
Ja, Höhe 1 ist auf jeden Fall nicht so sinnvoll.
Immerhin, es ist schon mal ein QR-Code.
So.
Warum ist denn das so langsam?
Ah.
Delay von 100 Millisekunden
nach jedem Draw.
Ja gut.
Das würde es natürlich erklären, dass das so langsam ist.
Gucken wir mal, ob es jetzt schneller ist,
wenn ich das Delay rausmache.
So, schauen wir mal.
Okay, okay, okay, das geht schon ein bisschen schneller.
Es ist immer noch langsam.
Das ist aber klar, dass es langsam ist.
Ich setze hier aktuell wirklich Pixel für Pixel und schreibe es direkt aufs Display.
Also, wenn man das schnell machen will, würde man das quasi in einen Buffer schreiben
und dann den kompletten Buffer aufs Display.
Und nicht Bit für Bit im Endeffekt.
Oder 2 Byte für 2 Byte, um genau zu sein.
so
aber das war mal die LVGL
wie kriegt man das Ding jetzt größer
wie macht der das hier
mal Element Size
ok Element Size
ich nenne das jetzt einfach Pixel Size
oder
hier mal
Pixel Size
gleich 4
und jetzt sagen wir
mal
Pixel Size
Pixel Size.
Was hat er eigentlich für Schmerzen gerade?
Was mag er nicht?
Is not captured.
Ach so.
Ach ne, jetzt geht...
Na, das ist ja wieder C++ und C interop.
Funktioniert ja manchmal nicht richtig.
Static.
Machen wir es einfach.
Ludl.
So, und jetzt wird nochmal
Jetzt wird nochmal geflasht
Ja, ich hab's auch grad gemerkt
Aber wir können das nicht capturen
Jetzt
Gucken wir, ob's jetzt besser aussieht
Pause Champ
Ha! Ein QR-Code
Massive
Easy
Er kann meinen Modus aktiviert
Wir haben einen QR-Code.
Ich mach dir noch mal eins größer.
Mach mal
sechs.
Ist es jetzt größer, Chat?
Ich habe nicht aufgepasst.
Habt ihr aufgepasst?
Ja, doch ein bisschen größer ist es jetzt, glaube ich.
Machen wir mal 8.
Hast du einen speziellen Use Case?
Ich habe einen Use Case.
Aber der ist just for fun.
Ich will, dass das Ding ein Access Point aufmachen kann.
Ja, oh, jetzt guck mal.
guck mal wie das passt leute das passt ja exakt auf das display drauf als wäre
es so geplant also ich will den access point aufmachen mit random meister
random meister es das id und passwort und du kannst dann mit deinem handy
einfach das ding scannen und kommst du den access point der esp aufmacht von
dort kommst du dann direkt auf die website und kannst dann deine wlan
credentials und sowas eingeben dass ich dann der controller für das was
auch immer er dann sonst noch macht, im
Svelan verbinden kann. Also
da brauchst du keine App oder so einen Scheiß, wie das
viele Chirakinesen-Hersteller machen,
dass die so eine dumme App installieren muss zum
Einrichten.
Da passt doch, ah ja, ja, noch daneben, stimmt,
wahrscheinlich passt das noch daneben, ja.
Wollen wir mal gucken,
ob das noch daneben passt.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, wo fangen wir denn an?
Bei 140 oder so.
Gucken wir mal, ob das noch daneben passt.
Mal gespannt.
Wahrscheinlich haben wir es jetzt kaputt gemacht.
Und?
Das sieht nicht so gut aus.
Achso
Ja Moment
Ich bin ja auch blöd
Stimmt ja auch nicht
Moment Moment Moment
Ja wir machen es anders
Wir machen es anders
Wir fangen einfach
Hier
Hier fangen wir einfach
An
bei
220.
Viel besser.
So, bam.
Spannend.
Flash Champ.
Achso, nochmal auf die Frage einzugehen.
Naja, fast.
Jetzt haben wir nur einen halben QR-Code, aber...
Frage, was wichtiger ist.
Der QR-Code oder...
Auf dem Display.
Um die Frage vom letzten Mal zu beantworten, man muss das jedes Mal flashen, damit man eine neue Firma draufkriegt und da was ändern kann.
Jedes Mal.
Die einzige Möglichkeit, das quasi live zu programmieren ist, wenn man das beispielsweise
mit MicroPython macht, dann schiebt man den MicroPython Interpreter da drauf und dann
kann man dann direkt da drauf editieren und ausführen.
Aber wenn man das mit C++ macht, quasi eine neue Firmware bildet und dann muss sie auch
erstmal neu drauf geflasht werden.
So.
so naja also ich würde mal sagen dass mit dem qr-code funktioniert und jetzt kommt der schwierige
part jetzt muss da text drauf und text können wir definitiv nicht mehr so einfach machen wie
hier man aktuell machen wir noch gar nichts großartig spannendes wir setzen einzelne
farben für einzelne pixel fahren und kopieren ein komplettes bitmap image drauf text ist deutlich
komplizierter und text rendering können wir auch nicht mehr selbst machen weil da hören erstens
meine skills dafür auf außerdem ist das eine halbe lebensaufgabe eine text render engine zu
bauen text rendering ist abfac hoch 10 deswegen nehmen wir eine library die das schon kann und
Und zwar nehmen wir LVGL.
LVGL ist ein ziemlich bekanntes Projekt für Embedded Graphics.
Damit kannst du alles Mögliche malen.
Damit kannst du auch User Interfaces malen.
An sich ist LVGL richtig nice.
Man hat nämlich auch einen Editor für User Interfaces und sowas.
LVGL Editor.
Da kann man quasi seine User Interfaces bauen hier in so Art HTML.
Guck, sowas hier zum Beispiel kann man dann quasi bauen.
In sowas ähnliches wie HTML.
Und da kommt dann quasi was raus, was ich direkt auf meinem Microcontroller kopieren kann.
Also mit Designer ist das quasi, so ein bisschen Visual Designer.
Das ist viel, viel schöner, damit User Interfaces zu bauen,
wie wenn man beispielsweise von Hand alle Sachen machen muss, wie, ah, okay, da unten gibt es jetzt irgendeinen Button und da soll ein Text drauf und wir drawen dann quasi einen Rectangle und darauf einen Text und sonst was.
Sobald es ein bisschen umfangreichere User Interfaces werden, das LVGL ist mega nice.
Aber so abgedrehtes Zeug machen wir heute nicht.
Einer der Gründe, warum ich LVGL verwenden will, ist, LVGL bringt nicht nur Button Widgets mit, Kalender Widgets und sowas, sondern auch ein QR-Code Widget.
Damit kann man QR-Codes malen.
Sowas kann man dann malen aufs Display direkt.
Da müssen wir uns nicht selbst drum kümmern, sondern LVGL macht das für uns.
Und LVGL kann natürlich auch Text malen.
und das probieren wir jetzt aus
da muss ich dazu sagen, ich gucke ein bisschen was ab
ich habe nämlich schon mit dem alten
T-Display mit LVGL
mal was gebaut
und da können wir uns jetzt ein bisschen was abgucken
weil
LVGL vom Scratch ist eklig
das habe ich keinen Bock drauf
deswegen gucken wir uns was ab
so, ich werde mal alles wieder löschen
hier
das da oben können wir theoretisch sogar mal auslagern
Ihr wollt, nennen wir es mal InitDisplay.
Viele Spiele nutzen STB TrueType.
Okay, habe ich keine Ahnung von.
Machen wir hier mal InitDisplay.
Jetzt können wir im Endeffekt einfach alles da rein kopieren.
InitDisplay.
Ein bisschen den Überblick behalten.
In the Display, activate Backlight.
Ist doch schon mal ganz gut.
Gut, auf geht's.
Dann brauchen wir jetzt...
Haben wir das vielleicht schon?
LVGL haben wir ja schon installiert.
Okay.
So, jetzt muss ich ein bisschen abgucken.
Und zwar...
Wo hab ich's denn?
Lasst mich mal kurz schauen.
Muss mal hier in meinem privaten Git, äh, nee, ist kein Git, GitLab, es ist ein Gitea.
Gucken.
So, wo hab ich's denn hier?
Main.
Display, das klingt gut.
Genau, Display.
Okay, hier geht's los.
ich habe das damals mir aus dem offiziellen beispiel zusammen gewurschtelt ja also es
gibt hier wenn ich hier nach lvgl suche gibt es lvgl für den esp 32 und hier steht eigentlich
drin wie es funktioniert nur ziemlich rudimentär da habe ich bestimmt letztes mal war ich nicht
45 tage rum gemacht bis das alles richtig funktioniert hat bis das gecheckt habe deswegen
nehmen wir jetzt das von dem ich weiß dass es funktionieren müsste weil es ist nicht exakt
für den controller sondern für eine ältere version brauchen als erstes das hier lv gl port in it und
danach brauchen wir lv in it sonst geht gar nichts
gut und jetzt kommt magic das muss ich mir angucken weil das wird garantiert
so nicht funktionieren also jetzt müssen wir einen eine port config anlegen
Wait a minute.
Da gibt es keine...
Wollen wir verarschen?
Kann doch nicht sein,
dass sich da nichts dazwischen geändert hat.
Anscheinend hat sich da nichts dran geändert.
Warum denn 20?
Buffer Size.
Pixel Höhe.
Mal 20.
20?
Warum 20?
Keine Ahnung, warum 20?
Buffer Size
Size of Buffers for the screen in pixels
Müsste das nicht eigentlich
Höhe mal Breite sein?
Ach, ich weiß warum 20.
Das ist garantiert zum Arbeitsspeicher sparen.
Weil die alten hatten ja nur 512 oder 510 KB RAM.
Und der hier hat jetzt einfach mal 8 MB RAM.
Die alten hatten ja viel weniger RAM.
Die alten Controller.
Ich glaube, ich habe einfach RAM gespart damit.
Ja.
wir lassen es mal so, es wird wahrscheinlich auch so funktionieren,
so, Breite mal Höhe, Monochrome Falls,
Swap Bytes, das müssen wir auf jeden Fall auf True stellen,
weil, ne, das haben wir gelernt hier, Swap Bytes muss auf True, sonst funzt es nicht,
wobei, jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wenn ich hier Bytes swappe,
und hier die Color Bytes swappe, kommt da nicht wieder was Falsches bei raus,
weil doppelt Swap heißt ja im Endeffekt gar nicht
geswappt
Swap XY genauso wie
Swap XY und Mirror
und Mirror
das machen wir hier
auch schon
ist die Frage, ist es jetzt quasi wieder
entswappt oder
entmirrored, wenn wir es da oben machen und hier unten
Dokumentation lesen
Wo kommen wir denn da hin jetzt?
Wir machen das immer first try richtig.
Documentation.
Da bin ich mir auch nicht sicher.
Moment.
Okay.
So.
Und jetzt brauchen wir damit LVGL Funst.
LVGL.
Port.
Was?
Port at
Display
Port
Config
Okay.
Ah, und das gibt jetzt ein Display Handle
zurück.
Kann man Static Auto machen?
Geht sowas?
Display Handle.
Okay, anscheinend
funktioniert das.
Display Handle.
Und dann habe ich hier noch zwei andere Sachen.
Da weiß ich nicht, ob ich die wirklich brauche.
Ich habe Set Anti-Aliasing.
Ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Ich muss es nicht aussprechen, oder?
Display of Falls.
Warum will ich Anti-Aliasing nicht haben?
Warum habe ich das auf Falls gesetzt?
Vielleicht weil es pixellig aussah mit?
Aber sollte Anti-Aliasing nicht eigentlich dazu beitragen, dass es nicht pixellig aussieht?
Set Default Display.
Set Default Display ist das Display Handle.
Okay.
Ja.
Und jetzt ist es angeblich ready, dass wir damit was malen können.
Schauen wir mal.
Ich meine, jetzt sollte das Display noch nichts machen.
Aber das Display sollte zumindest...
Es sollte jetzt auch nicht crashen, sagen wir mal so.
Was das Callback on Color Trends done was already said.
Ja, ja.
Weiß ich.
Der wird hier irgendwo gesetzt.
Der Callback.
ach kann ich das vielleicht rausnehmen jetzt einfach wenn es da unten
nochmal weg cool dann ist macht blut und verfälscht haben wenn alles dachte
eigentlich sollte gerade dazu beitragen dass das schön smooth ist anti-aliasing
ok
Das sieht übrigens hier nur
nur hier so aus.
Das Display, wenn ich drauf gucke,
sieht ganz okay aus.
Das ist ein bisschen
verbuggt wegen der Kamera hier,
was ihr seht.
So, und jetzt können wir mit LVGL malen.
Probieren wir das doch mal aus.
Mal gucken, ob...
Also hierfür habe ich jetzt nichts mehr.
Jetzt müssen wir mal gucken,
ob ich das noch irgendwie halbwegs...
Ne, Leute, ich habe keine Ahnung mehr.
Irgendwas mit Label.
Wir gucken mal in die Documentation.
Da freut sich der Chat.
Hier. Documentation.
Label.
Äh, ne.
Basic Examples.
Very simple Hello World Label.
Das ist genau das, was ich brauche.
Change active screens background color.
Das ist gut.
So was brauche ich.
So, active screen backup color.
Okay.
Das Funds das jetzt?
Schauen wir mal
Jetzt müsste der Bildschirm gleich blau werden
Der blau
Ah ne, der flasht noch
Okay, der flasht jetzt langsam, weil LVGL relativ groß ist
Ha!
Äh
Moment, blau?
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment
Moment, was ist das für eine Farbe?
Das ist rot.
Oh, nee.
Leute, wir haben wieder irgendwelche Fehler.
Wir haben wieder irgendwelche RGB-Color-Geschiss-Fehler.
Och, nee.
Okay, Chat, Chat, Chat.
Mal ganz, ganz normal.
Ist das überhaupt rot hier?
Ist das überhaupt rot?
RGB-Hacks.
Ne, das ist blau, okay
Ich lecke Critical Information
Okay, wir brauchen
Okay, Swap Bytes, Leute
Swap Bytes, False
Wir swappen ja aktuell Doppel Bytes
Deswegen
Ist es wiederum nicht geswappt
Wahrscheinlich muss man das jetzt auf False stellen
Beim Alten muss ich es auf True stellen
I lack Critical Information
Macht er, ich lecke hier wirklich Critical Information
Okay, es ist blau. Easy.
Easy fix.
Easy.
Nice.
Okay, wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Jetzt haben wir einen blauen Hintergrund.
Und jetzt...
Okay, ich kopiere mir den Kram einfach mal.
Jetzt Label.
Create.
LV Screen Active.
Okay, was auch immer.
Das wird schon hinhauen.
Hello World.
Nein, Cute Chat.
What?
Cute Chat.
Okay.
Set Text Color.
Äh.
Weiß.
Und jetzt Label Alliance Center heißt wahrscheinlich, dass in der Mitte vom Hut-Element angezeichnet
wird.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Bin ich mal gespannt, ob das funzt.
Zeige ich hier.
Ah!
Ich muss mir das selbst mal kurz angucken.
Wie sieht denn der Text aus?
Sieht der Text gut oder schlecht aus?
Wartet mal, ich muss mal kurz ein bisschen...
Na
Oh na ja
So schlecht sieht der Text gar nicht
Und sieht eigentlich ganz brauchbar aus der Text
Doch der Text sieht ganz brauchbar aus
Mal gucken, warte, pass mal auf
Das sieht eigentlich ganz brauchbar aus
Der Text, wenn ich mir das hier mal so in groß angucke
Das sieht ziemlich
ordentlich aus.
Wir machen den Text mal ein bisschen größer.
Okay, wir machen den Text mal ein bisschen größer.
Dann sehen wir nämlich auch mehr, ob es Pixel
gibt oder nicht an den Ecken.
Wie ändert man
denn jetzt
die Text Size?
Text Color.
Okay. Gibt es sowas wie
LV Text
Size?
jetzt sei es gibt es okay es gibt jetzt aber es gibt nicht setzte ist das schon
mal irgendwie doof lvgl text ist der way to change label text
wie das muss ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass der grafik leib mit
irgendwie 3000 sterne keine texte setzen kann der text und need to change the
font of the label using styles
ich hole mir battlefield 6 ja und ich denke mal ich werde auch ein paar runden
wenn es in sechs stream so ja ja ja denk schon ist ja gar nicht mal lang noch 14
tage oder so
Chatge, was machen die da?
Set Text Font?
Arial, gibt es das bei mir?
Arial 70? Nö.
Ich weiß, dass das geht.
Ich habe damit schon Text in unterschiedlichen Sizes gemalt.
Weiß, dass das prinzipiell funktioniert.
die hier zeigen wieder somit pri pri die gedenkstext funktioniert aber das
konnte ich weiß dass das dass das ging ich weiß bloß immer wie
roboter
Roboto den Text habe ich noch irgendwo als Header File.
Kann doch nicht sein.
in Fonts. Ach, es gibt mehrere
Fonts. LV
Font.
LV Font. Was? Mon?
Achso. Ah, ich hab nur ein Font.
Nämlich den 14er.
Es ging aber.
Ich weiß, dass es ging.
Ich bin mir... Ich weiß
so nicht mehr wie.
Ich weiß genau,
dass das Funste...
Guck mal, loading a font at runtime.
GTF.
GTF klingt gut.
Tiny
TTF Font Engine.
Ach, guck mal hier,
STB TrueType, hat das nicht gerade jemand in den Chat geschrieben?
Ich glaube, das war das.
Hat doch gerade jemand auch
in den Text eliminiert, wie man früher
gesagt hat.
Usage.
Ja, das kommt.
Ja, genau. So war das.
Ich erinnere mich. Warum kann man das nicht
kommen?
Mein Browser hat gerade abgestürzt.
Mein Browser hängt. Leute.
Mein Browser benutzt einen CPU-Kern
für ich weiß nicht genau was.
Bitcoin Miner aktiviert.
Alter.
Die Seite crasht meinen Browser.
Stopp.
Ach, jetzt geht es, oder was?
Das hat einfach meinen kompletten Browser gecrasht.
mit connect ja die sind es bestimmt das suche ich lv tiny ttf create data ubuntu von ubuntu sei es
genau das suche ich das habe ich das habe ich gesucht hier set von set
genau das habe ich gesucht jetzt brauchen wir nur noch den fond
Jetzt brauchen wir nur noch den Font.
Wo kriege ich denn den Font her?
Font? In welchem Format eigentlich?
TTF dann, oder?
Okay, Roboto, nehmen wir mal.
TTF, ein ganz nicer Font.
Moment, ich brauche Roboto
brauche ich als
ähm
als
C-Header-File
und
äh
Roboto.ttf
C-Header
gibt es das schon irgendwo fertig ich habe das irgendwo auch noch rumliegen
convert to see herr der fall
ja da konvertiert das ist so ein random projekt von github nehme ich jetzt dass dich
lv von konf
Aha
Ne, das will ich ja nicht
Ich will ja
Ich will ja keinen
Keinen LVGL-Fond
Ich will ja einen TTF-Fond
Den ich dann dynamisch laden kann
Okay, lass mich mal kurz mein GitHub durchsuchen
Äh, mein lokales GTA durchsuchen
Ich hab ja noch
Irgendwo hab ich das ja noch
So, mal hier.
Roboto.
Ah ja, guck mal da.
Roboto.h
Das klingt gut, Leute.
Generated by.
Okay.
Kann ich mich trauen, auf diese Webseite zu gehen?
Okay Leute, ich hab hier
einen Pfeil. Schauen wir mal, ob das funzt.
Das ist einfach nur ein langes
C-Array.
Boah, was viel zu lang ist.
Ich krieg's gar nicht markiert komplett.
Copy, Paste.
Und das ist jetzt hier einfach.
Jetzt hängt mein Browser auf der anderen Seite.
Geil.
Meine Güte.
OKS
Raw File
Hier, ok, so, ich hab's
New
Error File
Roboto.h
Zack
Da ist er, Leute
Hab ich wohl
Irgendwann mal hier generiert
Keine Ahnung
Hoffen wir mal, dass es funzt
Also
Wenn nicht, müssen wir jetzt irgendwo was Neues generieren
Roboto Mono Bowl Subset
Subset, ich habe wahrscheinlich nicht
Mit allen möglichen Characters
Generiert
sondern nur mit a bis z 0 bis 9 und sowas drin und jetzt machen wir was
Irgendwie ist das ziemlich am kaputt gehen gerade.
Was not declared in scope.
Was muss ich denn dafür includen, dass das funzt?
Aber hier Roboto haben wir.
Roboto.
LV Tiny TTF.
Wie? Moment.
Warum ist...
Was muss ich denn includen dafür?
Include?
Ah, kann sein, dass ich das zusätzliche
aktivieren muss vorher.
TTF Rendering.
TTF.
Ah.
Was?
Enable Tiny TTF.
Decoder?
Äh.
das ist jetzt das richtige
ok
ich will das gar nicht flaschen egal ich flashe noch mal
Oh, jetzt brauche ich aber viel CPU-Last gerade.
Das hier ist übrigens
Size of.
Okay, das hört sich gut an.
Es ist zumindest schon mal nicht abgekackt, weil er das hier nicht findet.
Okay, dann können wir das mal ausprobieren.
Machen wir mal hier Auto-Font.
Und wie setze ich den Font jetzt?
Set Text.
Machen wir LV Label.
Set.
E-Font.
Font.
warte mal steht auch hier hat mich ein beispiel create text von
11 style
label text
ich check jetzt gerade nicht so ganz
was ich machen muss.
Wie jetzt? Set Text?
Font? Kann ich nicht
einfach
Set Style machen?
Das checke ich nicht.
LV Style Init?
Warum ist das so kompliziert?
Mal kurz was gucken.
Doch, das geht.
Da habe ich doch recht.
Man kann einfach
hier vorne
das Label angeben
und dann
meinen Font.
Oh, kann man nicht?
Hä?
Ah, Moment.
Es gibt ja noch mehr.
Ich hab hier
Weil ich hab ja noch ein Projekt, wo ich das schon mal benutzt hab
Da hab ich aus irgendwelchen Gründen auch 0 hinten angegeben
Aber das geht auch nicht
LV Style
Ich bin verwirrt
Hä?
Ich habe hier ein Label.
Label Create habe ich gemacht.
Nochmal Label.
Was will er denn?
Was hat er für Schmerzen?
Leute, ich bin super
jetzt verwirrt. Ich hab noch
ein Beispiel hier, da wo ich auch diese Roboto
Header her kopiert hab.
Da mach ich das genauso.
Oder bin ich jetzt irgendwie blind?
Moment, sag was.
Die T-Watch, okay, die basiert auf einem ESP-Kanal.
Ja, wenn das ein ESP32 mit Display ist, kannst du mit LVGL alles mögliche machen.
LVGL ist ja nur die Grafik-Library.
Ja, ja.
Das kannst du machen.
das geht aber ich bin jetzt echt verwirrt dass das net funktioniert was habe ich denn
hier gemacht in dem an in diesem anderen projekt vielleicht ist das eine andere 11
die l version die ich damals benutzt habe oder es hier funktioniert hat set text von
weil da muss man ein style übergeben
Guck ich kann euch das sagen
Ich hab eins zu eins das hier so gemacht
So
So ein Label
Label ist halt im Endeffekt
Das heißt bei mir jetzt nicht L sondern Label
Und der Font
Heißt halt so hier
Hä
Hä?
Puh.
Ist das was anderes jetzt?
LV Style und Object Set Style.
Ach du Scheiße.
Oh.
Okay.
Ja, kaum macht man es richtig, siehe da, funktioniert es.
So, und übrigens hier den Hintergrund, den machen wir mal schwarz.
Black.
Ist auch gescheit ausgleich.
So, jetzt sollten wir eine Roboto-Schrift mit Schriftgröße 30 in der Mitte bekommen.
Boah, der sieht richtig gut aus, oder?
Das ist wirklich schön.
Weicher Text.
Das sieht richtig gut aus.
Boah, gestochen.
Gestochen, scharfer Text, ohne irgendwelche Kanten oder irgendwelche anderen Dinger.
Das ist schön.
Das gefällt mir.
Ich bin...
Okay, jetzt bin ich aber doch mal interessiert dran, warum...
wie sieht das mit anti-aliasing aus
also auf der online seite steht plus lcd ich habe eigentlich gedacht es ist ein oled aber
vielleicht ist es das auch nicht bei mir steht hier nur drauf t display s 31,9 inch 8 bit lcd
Also wahrscheinlich tatsächlich nur ein LCD.
Ich hätte aber eigentlich auch gedacht, dass es ein OLED ist.
Aber ist es wohl anscheinend nicht.
Okay, ich erkenne keinen Unterschied mit und ohne Anti-Aliasing.
Dann machen wir das Falls wieder.
Ja, die Kamera verfälscht es ein bisschen.
Aber es sieht wirklich gut aus.
Sieht wirklich gestochen scharf aus, der Text.
Sehr gut.
Dann, da können wir uns jetzt mal um den QR-Code kümmern, würde ich sagen.
Also, das funzt.
Dann, dann tun wir doch mal so, als schreiben wir da jetzt was, ähm, SSID, cute chat.
Okay, so.
Moment, Moment, wartet mal, wartet mal.
Ich will mal was probieren.
Wir machen mal eine Schleife.
Ich will mal gucken, wie viel maximal Text,
wie groß man den Text machen kann.
Keine Ahnung, wir machen mal
bis 120.
Okay?
Okay.
Warte mal.
Label Create gibt es hier oben.
Textcolor
gibt es auch hier oben.
Font.
Text.
Auch hier oben.
Hier will ich nur den Font machen.
Die Frage ist, muss man den Font
wieder
wieder freen irgendwie?
TTF free?
Oder sowas?
Weil das Memory liegt doch wahrscheinlich
sonst
wie verrückt.
Oder nicht?
Hm.
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht,
man muss das bestimmt wieder... Ah, destroy!
Okay.
Manchmal finde ich es cool, wenn man es einfach
free nennt, weil irgendwie heißt alles free
und man gewöhnt sich dran, wenn was free heißt.
Was jetzt destroy heißt,
ist ein bisschen unintuitiv.
Dann label.
Also wisst ihr, was ich jetzt mal probieren will?
Ich will das einfach mal
mit unterschiedlichen Textgrößen.
Machen wir hier i.
Mal malen. Jetzt machen wir hier mal ein Delay.
Delay von
10 Millisekunden rein.
So, da sollte doch jetzt eigentlich...
Ach so, Moment, Moment.
Ähm.
klärt er jetzt eigentlich den screen wenn ich das so mache schau mal vielleicht ist
jetzt mal also was sie was er jetzt machen sollte ist er sollte einfach immer wieder
immer größer werden den text malen schauen wir mal aber das macht
Oh.
Wow.
MonkaS?
Was hab ich denn jetzt kaputt gemacht?
Was ist daran jetzt falsch?
Ich hab den Wachhund ausgelöst
Ja
Was ist daran jetzt verkackt?
Warum funzt das nicht?
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, er malt hier immer größer
Wenn er einen Text
Was hat er?
Passt mal auf, was ist, wenn ich den Text nicht destroyer?
Liegt das daran, dass ich
Den Text destroyer, der noch angezeigt wird?
Vielleicht muss ich das ganze Label destroyen
Dass das funzt
Ich kann nicht einfach den Text destroyen, während es noch auf dem
label angezeigt wird das wird wahrscheinlich funktionieren
vielleicht ist es das schau mal ja das flächen dauern lange aber was willst du
machen
ok also jetzt zeigt er zumindest schon mal was an und startet immer wieder neu
warum
Wahrscheinlich, weil der RAM ausgeht, kann es sein.
Puh.
Nee.
Ähm.
Wartet mal.
Wartet mal, Moment mal, Moment mal.
Label create.
Ah, Moment.
Mit Rust wäre...
Das ist tatsächlich was, was mit Rust nicht passiert wäre.
Ich habe eine Idee.
Kann das sein?
Dass wir den Font
erst destroyen dürfen?
Wenn wir einen neuen haben?
Warte mal.
Wir machen mal kurz hier was.
Ich probiere mal was.
Font hier keinen 30. Okay.
So. Jetzt sagen wir destroy font.
wird er jetzt wird der alte fonds destroyed so aber hier legen wir jetzt
9 aber das geht ja nichts bringt ja nix
Das bringt also nichts.
Okay.
Dann müssen wir uns das irgendwie kopieren.
Auto.
Irgendwie keine Ahnung.
Old Font.
So.
Dann legen wir einen neuen an.
Setzen den.
Und jetzt destroyen wir den alten.
Ist das okay jetzt?
Okay.
Es crasht schon mal nicht.
Wie geht das jetzt?
Ich will einfach nur mal gucken, wie die unterschiedlichen Textsachen aussehen.
Das Funsnet, was ich hier mache, das ist irgendwie...
Jetzt habe ich den Watchdog wieder getriggert.
Anyway, also irgendwas mache ich hier grundsätzlich verkehrt.
So. Es könnte ja
natürlich sein, dass man
das alles in einem machen muss.
Also, dass man hier das ganze
Label-Gedöns
hier drinnen machen muss.
Damit es funktioniert.
Ich lösche jetzt mal gar nichts.
Aber wir machen jetzt
kein Memory
Wir produzieren jetzt einen Memory-Leak.
Absichtlich.
Okay, nee, Leute.
Ich bin da zu dumm für.
Keine Ahnung.
Okay.
Ich krieg nicht hin.
Du hast doch unterschiedliche Texte.
Die unterschiedliche Größe.
Macht das das?
Ach, das macht es.
Macht es.
Du hast recht.
Aber dann geht der RAM aus wahrscheinlich
Oder zu viele Labels oder so
Das macht's ja
Okay
Ich cleare nicht, das stimmt
Und ich muss, aber ich muss den Font
Destroyen, wenn ich den nicht destroye
Aber das, das, das crasht
Bestimmt, wenn ich den, den lösche wieder
Nachdem ich
Ne, ne, ich darf
Den Font nicht löschen, nachdem er schon auf dem Display
Drauf ist
Hä?
Jetzt macht er wieder nix.
Achso.
Ich check's nicht.
Okay, also.
Es ist komplizierter, als ich mir das vorgestellt hab.
Einfach in immer größer werdenden...
Ich darf den nicht löschen, weil das Label den noch verwendet.
Sobald ich den lösche, dann mag er nicht mehr.
Hä?
Nee, guck jetzt von uns.
Das Funds nur...
Es kann doch nicht sein, dass das so kompliziert ist.
Das Laden der Fonts...
Ich will das doch dynamisch.
Ich will das doch dynamisch haben.
Ich will doch pro Schleifen durchlaufend quasi ein Font laden
mit einer anderen Font Size.
You can destroy font after all widgets that used have been deleted. Ja, okay.
Aber wenn ich das Widget lösche, ich erstelle ja immer neue Widgets.
das ist ja wenn ich das label die liete ist es ja weg dann zeigt da gar nichts
mal an lv label ist treu oder irgendwie das treu
speicher alle font sizes im rand
warte mal warte mal wie löscht man überhaupt was lvgl free object
LV
Object Clean
Label
So
So.
LV-Object clean.
Danach Destroy.
Aber dann löscht er das doch auch gleich wieder.
Wenn ich das so mache, dann sehe ich gar nichts mehr auf dem Display.
Übrigens, ich sehe in meinem Beispiel gerade noch was.
Ich glaube, ich mache das prinzipiell verkehrt.
weil, lass mal gucken, was er jetzt macht, wahrscheinlich macht er jetzt gar nichts,
ne, jetzt macht er gar nichts, weil, pass mal auf, wo habe ich es eben gefunden,
man muss anscheinend, wo habe ich denn die Display, hier, man muss anscheinend die Sachen rappen,
wenn man sowas macht, wie ich hier mache,
muss man rappen
in
lvgl
port lock.
Das ist wahrscheinlich, dass es Threadsafe ist
am Ende. Und dann
lv, Dings, port unlock.
Aber kann die Größe ändern im Nachhinein
Ach man muss gar nicht immer
Einen neuen Font erstellen
Ach so, ja viel besser
Dann ist der okay, dann ist easy
Dann ist ja easy
Dann legen wir den Font hier an mit keine Ahnung
Schriftgröße, irgendwas, scheiß drauf
So, Label
Das Gedöns können wir auch da raus schmeißen.
Font können wir auch raus schmeißen.
Das Clean, das sparen wir uns einfach, weil ich den Font nicht löschen will.
Set Size.
Hier.
Font.
Und dann Size I.
Okay.
Schauen wir mal, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Jetzt müsste es eigentlich gehen.
Auf Flash Champ.
Flash mal ein bisschen schneller.
Kann das sein, dass ich...
Was ist das?
Zu schnelles?
Oder dass ich das mit dem Lock und Unlock da drinnen machen muss, wenn er malt.
Boah, das ist richtig High IQ-Live.
Das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Jetzt macht er gar nichts.
Alter, ich check den Kram nicht.
Achso.
Ach, Moment.
Ach, der macht Unlock erst.
Kann das sein, dass ich im Endeffekt sowas hier machen muss?
Dass es funktioniert?
Kann LVGL die Fonts als dynamisch ändern?
Zeigt selber das Lame.
Jaja, ich brauche keinen extra
Jetzt malen Aufruf.
Ah.
Oder auch nicht.
Ey, ich komme mir gerade richtig dumm vor
Two Head, Alter
Warum geht denn das nicht?
Was hat er denn für Schmerzen?
Was mag der nicht?
Was mag er nicht?
An so einem einfachen Kram brauchen wir wieder 3 Stunden.
Muss ich hier vielleicht auch sowas machen?
Hier auch quasi vorher?
Jetzt mal auf 120.
Aber warum
streichelt er erst?
Ne.
Gibt es denn nicht eine Loop Funktion?
Was?
Das ist doch eine Loop, das ist ein Vorschleif.
Ich bin jetzt echt
richtig verwirrt.
Ich check's nicht.
Das ärgert mich.
Warum ist das so kompliziert?
Muss ich vielleicht
Set Style jedes Mal neu machen?
Nachdem ich die Size geändert hab?
Vielleicht das?
Zugang Zugang
Zugang nach Zugang nach Zugang nach Zugang nach Zugang nach Zugang nach Zugang nach Zugang
Easy.
Easy as fuck.
Da musst du erstmal drauf kommen, oder?
Okay, jetzt können wir das Ganze auch ein bisschen schneller machen.
so label war nicht center machen 11 allein left top flächen oder 11 report
style change
reports notify all objects of style is modif
Und was soll ich da jetzt übergeben?
Was soll ich da jetzt übergeben?
Das Label wird es ja nicht sein, oder?
Den Font, oder wie?
Ne.
Dann weiß ich nicht.
Wäre es möglich, dass man einen Stundenplan einrichten könnte?
Und das Problem ist, ich war ja selbst immer nicht im Vorfeld,
von dem ich strebe.
Wenn ich irgendwie
einen Plan hätte, dann würde ich es machen.
So, jetzt muss ich auch mal kurz zugucken, wie das hier aussieht.
Ah, guckt mal, Leute.
Es funzt.
Pogu.
Wir machen jetzt nochmal eine Endlosschleife drum.
Einfach, weil es so schön ist.
Wir machen jetzt einen endlosen Textscroll.
Nice.
Meistens irgendwann so...
Man kann es halt wirklich nicht sagen, wann ich strebe, ne?
Mal irgendwie mitten am Tag, mal abends.
das einzige feste der einzig halbwegs feste termin ist sonntag morgens
ja das ist der einzig halbwegs feste termin
es ist es nicht nice guck mal seht ihr mal seht ihr da unten leute das hat sogar
einen scroll balken wie auch immer was auch immer mir das bringen soll dass das
scrollen kann aber immerhin.
By the way, dieses Screen-Tearing was ihr hier manchmal seht, das klickt an der
Kamera. Soll ich mal umschalten auf 60 FPS?
Das juckt ihn überhaupt nicht, was ich hier einstelle.
Deswegen bleibe ich jetzt einfach mal auf 50.
Ich glaube, das liegt an OBS.
Das, weil ich OBS anhabe.
Okay. Nice.
Das Board war...
Was soll da gerostet sein?
Wo ist da was gerostet?
Meinst du das hier?
Meinst du das?
Das ist ein durchsichtiges Ding mit Kabeln drin, wo das Display an Bord angeschlossen ist.
Das ist Kupfer, was du hier drunter siehst.
Das sind Kupfer-Traces.
In einem durchsichtigen Plastik-Ding.
Kein Rost.
Ja, oder vielleicht ist das Plastik da drum ein bisschen gelblich.
Ja, das kann sein.
aber da ist nichts gerostet.
Ja, nice, dann haben wir das hier mal.
Also, dann können wir jetzt ja auch mal was hinführen.
Nachdem wir jetzt eine komplett sinnlose 20 Minuten rumgebastelt gemacht haben,
weil wir das ja eigentlich gar nicht machen wollen,
wissen wir jetzt aber, wie es funktioniert.
Wir können sagen, hier, Font Size 30
und dann löschen wir das alles mal wieder.
von size 16 glaube ich deutlich sinniger ssr die youtube chat und jetzt gibt es ein
qr code qr code können wir direkt mit lv gl qr code rendern
ok und zwar ich copy paste mir war das komplette beispiel aber das hier mal rein so zack
hier geht es ja okay light blue blue 11 qr code create gibt es schon mal nicht warum
nicht gibt es auch nicht zu importieren ok müssen wir wahrscheinlich wieder menü
config einschalten qr code qr code library
bild wie findest du lvgl bisher bis sie umständlich aber ich weiß dass für wenn
man damit wirklich ein paar widgets auch malen muss ist das beste was es gibt für
mobile zeug wenn ich mobile zeug was habe ich für microcontroller zeug
gibt nichts besseres aber es ist gerade wenn man das nicht oft macht ist die
handhabung hat ein bisschen ungewohnt und unendlich
okay jetzt malen wir mal ein qr code bei nimmer braun bin ich in dem den
standard qr code den der jetzt da beispiel drin ist
ok flash bin ich mal gespannt was der macht überschreibt der qr code jetzt
den text gut das überlagert sich halt
aber wir haben qr code bin begeistert sogar relativ hübschen qr code
Was wir jetzt machen können ist
Okay, pass mal auf
Wie kriegen wir den QR-Code?
Achso
Äh
Chat, warum
Ich hab mal ne blöde Frage
Ach hier, LV Object Center
Das ist doch das, was ich gesucht hab
Object Align
Machen wir jetzt
QR-Code
LV-Align
Bottom-Right
0,0
Jetzt sollte es eigentlich passen.
Jetzt sollte das so...
Jetzt sollte es so weit auseinander sein, dass beides drauf passt.
Ja.
Okay.
Haben wir einen QR-Code.
Warte mal.
Jetzt müssen wir mal testen, ob der QR-Code an sich auch funzt.
Ist auch der alte.
Äh.
Wait a minute.
Irgendwas ist hier ein bisschen verbuggt.
Snap.
Äh, nein.
Meine Gott, warum nervt Windows immer so QR-Code?
LVGLIO.
Stimmt.
Richtig.
Gut, dann brauchen wir jetzt noch einen WLAN-String.
Generate WLAN-String QR-Code.
Hier, da steht's.
Wifi SSID
TWPA
Okay das brauchen wir jetzt da drinnen
Als Data
Also Wifi
SSID
SSID hatten wir ja gesagt ist cute
Chat
T ist höchstwahrscheinlich
WPA
Und das ist das Passwort
Passwort ist
Ne okay vielleicht doch
Doch das ist das Passwort
Wenn wir jetzt alles
Funds, sollten wir einen QR-Code
bekommen. Wenn man den mit dem Handy scannt,
will er sich verbinden.
Wäre nice, wenn das gleich mal jemand ausprobieren
könnte, weil ich glaube, mit Windows kann man das nicht ausprobieren.
Guck mal, jetzt sieht er auch schon ein bisschen
komplexer aus. Schauen wir mal, was Windows
macht, wenn man das hier...
Okay, da erkennt man den Text.
chat könnt ihr könnt ihr mal versuchen den qr-code auf dem display zu scannen
ob das ich jetzt versucht ob der sagt funzt ja iphone sagt wlan q chat
beitreten sehr schön weiß dann funzt das was ich vorhatte so geht das
Ich meine, wir haben jetzt keinen Access Point offen.
Das machen wir vielleicht das nächste Mal.
Ich habe keinen Access Point offen.
Und wir haben auch kein Webinterface, um irgendwas zu machen oder so.
Es ging ja nur mal um den theoretischen Fall, wenn man dann sowas hätte, wie man das dann auf dem Display anzeigen würde.
Samsung geht auch. Ja, ich glaube, dass das funktioniert.
Also, danke fürs Nachgucken.
Chat ist wieder voll dabei.
er sagt aber dass das netzwerk network nicht gibt ja das auch klar wird mich auch wundern
wenn es das gibt da würde ich blöd gucken wenn es bei euch den wlan qt chat gibt mit diesem passwort
code ging einfach 20 mal so schnell wie schriftgröße ja das stimmt schon
schriftgröße ändern war entgegner heute
okay was wir jetzt noch machen können wir tun jetzt mal so als wäre das hier ein echtes projekt
sagen jetzt ssid cute chat und dass es noch eindeutig ist kriegen wir die mac adresse
Gehen wir in die MAC Adresse von dem Ding.
return base mecha switch factory programm also ja das ist
achtbar jetzt okay
dazu irgendwie ein gescheites example
Chat, warum ist es bei dem nur 6 Bytes?
Wenn es der Fall ist.
Jetzt haben wir die MAC-Adresse.
Das ist ja auch wieder was anderes.
Moment, 6 Bytes
Ist ja auch richtig
So, jetzt haben wir hier die MAC Adresse
Drinnen in Bytes
Wie im OK
Ach, guck mal hier
Wobei, wir können die ruhig als Int lassen
Als Int ist auch vollkommen OK
Und jetzt
sagen wir hier
FMT
Sprintf?
Ne, äh
VSprintf?
Ach Gott, wie?
Format, ne, Format
Format
Ähm, Format
Moment, wie formatiert man dann?
FMT-Lib, Format.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, warte mal.
Chat, Chat, mal langsam.
Das sind sechs Bytes.
Können wir vielleicht...
Können wir vielleicht das in ein...
In ein Int64...
In ein Int64 casten?
Haben wir sowas?
Uint...
Moment, aber wenn ich das jetzt in ein Int64 caste...
Moment, funzt das?
oder nimmt er dann zwei Bytes
mehr dabei und ich lese
random aus dem Arbeitsspeicher irgendwas aus.
Was passiert
wenn ich sechs Bytes
zu einem UN64 caste?
Wieso überhaupt
Int? Naja, ich will ja irgendeine random Nummer
also die Nummer von die Mac
in die
Mac Adresse halt anzeigen.
Ist das safe, was ich hier mache?
Checkt er das, ja.
Bam!
Kunst!
Jetzt haben wir hier eine SSID.
Jetzt müssen wir nur noch gucken, wie macht man da jetzt einen Zeilenumbruch rein.
Kann man jetzt hier sagen, SSID, check der Zeilenumbruch.
Use Functionals.
Wait a minute, das Funst.
chat was bin ich hier sehen hat hat hat das den konstruktor der der
einen bei der reppen was sehe ich hier was ist das warum kann ich sagen und 64
Ich hab legit absolut keine Ahnung, was hier gerade passiert.
Aber guck mal, das ist für uns.
Jetzt haben wir eine Randomized der SSID und einen QR-Code. Bloß dass der QR-Code
natürlich nicht stimmt. Wir müssen mal das hier kurz auslagern.
QR Code Format muss ja so sein.
Achso.
Warte mal.
Moment.
Ah.
Haben wir hier die SSID.
Format.
möglicherweise haben wir eine gescheite Format Library
und den QR Code Text
komm ich hab jetzt keinen Bock
darum zu wurschteln
Okay, hat mir irgendwas kaputt gemacht?
Ich hoffe nicht
Hör auf, Flashchamp
mal ein bisschen schneller
Ja
Okay, gut, Pfunst
haben wir hier auch das passwort mit drin schön ist es nicht können das hier jetzt nämlich einfach
sparen das da können wir machen wenn hier sagen wer text längst wollen weiß soll ich will sagen
haben wir es oder? Also es funzt.
Es funzt.
Wir haben die SSID auf dem Display stehen.
Jetzt nervt nicht mit der Framerate rum.
Wir haben die SSID auf dem
Display stehen und wir haben einen QR-Code,
wo diese SSID
drin steht und das
Passwort, um sich dahin zu connecten.
Das finde ich sehr nice.
Nice-u, würde ich sagen.
Massive Nice.
Da waren wir erfolgreich heute.
Immer.
Ja, du hast recht.
Das richtige Mindset.
Muss man ja haben.
Was sieht eigentlich den Knopf hier drücke?
Flashbang passiert dann.
Schon eine MX Master 4 bestellt?
Nee, warum sollte ich?
Dennis, danke schön für den Sub.
Die absolut sinnlosen sind Vibrance.
Vibrance.
Hochgestellt.
Ich lasse da mal die Finger vorn.
Ich glaube, das ist besser.
Ja, Leute.
Da haben wir es.
Hat funktioniert.
Erfolgreicher Strick.
Achso, wartet mal, wir probieren nochmal eine Sache.
Ähm.
Können wir nicht einfach sagen,
äh, LV Black,
LV White,
dann sieht das,
dann sieht das nicht so pepege aus
mit dem Blau.
war das mit der mac jetzt wirklich richtig anscheinend
anscheinend schon
was mal wieder im tierheim ja aber das ist schon ein paar wochen her da war ich wieder
da hier in hier um die ecke im tierheim die so eine große katzenstation mit außen gehege und so haben
ich brauche kein border
Oder ist overrated, outdated, she baited.
Das schreibt doch den Pointer rein.
Nee.
Ich hab...
Achso.
Ah, du hast recht.
Du hast recht.
Oder?
Also wenn schon, müsste ich es mal dereferenzen
eigentlich, dass überhaupt was Sinnvolles bei rauskommt.
Moment, du hast recht.
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, was ich da mache.
Weil das ändert sich auch
jedes Mal.
Aber guck mal, jetzt sieht der
QR-Code besser aus. Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ähm.
Cast
int array to int.
C
Convert to Intent
Ok, best
Nein
Das geht doch gar... nein, nein, nein, nein
Das kann man doch garantiert irgendwie casten
Hä?
Das geht doch 100 pro geht das
irgendwie
Du kannst doch, du kannst doch nen
Du musst doch einen Byte-Array interpretieren können als...
Warte mal.
Ne, 2.15 ist richtig.
So kann man übrigens auch machen.
2.15 ist richtig.
Ich hab, ich hab nen Byte Array doch noch klar.
Das ist ein Byte Array mit 6, mit 6 Plätzen drin.
Also Char ist halt gleich wie Byte im Endeffekt der Plattform.
Er ist doch immer ein Pointer.
Oder bin ich jetzt total verwirrt?
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Moment Chat.
warte mal
ist das jetzt
ein Array
oder ist das ein Array mit
Char, achso das ist ein String Array
hey
Moment
ich hab nen Array mit 6
Char Pointer drin
Ach so.
Ach, da ist schon Text drin.
Also müsste ich im Endeffekt...
Ach so, ja, dann ist doch easy.
Dann ist doch easy.
FMT-Format.
Also im Endeffekt...
So.
Das geht bestimmt schöner, aber...
Oh, hier.
Mac Base.
0.
So.
Ups, wenn man das nochmal richtig macht.
6 so
ach ja nur bis fünf du hast recht ja
aber hier vorne sind sechs stück
Und nochmal ein Minus dazwischen.
So, und jetzt kann ich hier die MAC-Adresse nehmen.
Und da hinhauen.
So, schauen wir mal.
Ach so.
Was hat der jetzt für...
...für Schmerz?
Wo ist jetzt das Problem?
Was hat der jetzt für Probleme?
Geile, beste Fehlermeldung aller Zeiten.
Der hat Probleme.
Alter, was ist das für eine Fehlermeldung, Mann?
Er kann hier irgendwas nicht formaten.
Und warum kann er nicht formaten?
Großes Problem.
Formatting of non-void pointers.
Der soll ja auch keine Pointer formatten.
Der soll...
Der soll String...
Formatten.
Char Pointer.
nein ich will auch kein point formatiert ich will dass er den den string davon
nimmt
ist teilweise schon ziemliche abfall
wie formatiert man das denn jetzt
ja keine ahnung
ich war die referenzen muss ich höchstwahrscheinlich nicht da kommt genau
genau ein schar bei raus das kann es ja nicht sein
warte mal warte mal fmt lip string array
Wie printe ich einen Vektor von Chars?
Was?
Ja, ne, das sind doch Buchstaben hier.
Weil das ist doch ein Array mit Pointer zu Strings, oder?
Aber ich verstehe nicht, warum das dann funktioniert.
Ich muss doch jetzt bestimmt nicht irgendwie noch sowas hier sagen, oder?
Dann kotze ich aber.
Muss ich irgendwie sowas machen?
Naja, natürlich nicht.
Ich habe absolut keinen Plan.
Das hier ist doch...
Das hier ist doch ein...
Das ist ein String im Endeffekt.
Und warum geht das nicht?
Weil das vielleicht unsigned ist?
Was ist denn... Warte mal, warte mal.
Was ist denn, wenn ich das einfach nur zu...
Zu char...
Dings...
Geht das... Oh, Leute. Wir testen das mal kurz.
Ach, das geht!
Alter!
Ey, diese Sprache, Mann!
Oh!
String Pointer ist
Null?
Wie kann der Null sein?
Alter, warum ist so eine Scheiße so kompliziert?
Das kann doch nicht der hier im Ernst sein.
So, ich frage jetzt ChatGPT.
Ich frage jetzt ChatGPT jetzt vorbei.
So.
Easy.
Achso.
Ach, ich wurde
jebaited. Ich wurde
jebaited von dem
Kack-Forums-Eintrag.
Ich wurde
hardcore jebaited von dem Forums-Eintrag.
Den ganzen Shit brauche ich nicht.
Jetzt kann ich aber das machen, was ich ursprünglich machen wollte, oder?
Oh.
In 6...
Die MAC-Adresse.
Einfach in...
Aber was ist mit den 2 Bytes, die ein U in 64 mehr hat?
Hardcore Cheap-Aided, Alter.
Oh Gott, Cheap-Aided.
Ha!
Das sieht auch nicht richtig aus.
Möchtest du jetzt dereferenzieren, dass das funzt?
Ne, okay, was sagt es?
Ach, Moment, da gibt es schon eine fertige...
Eine fertige Funktion?
Okay.
Jetzt kann ich das machen, was ich vorher eigentlich machen wollte, oder?
Jetzt kann ich das machen, was ich vorher eigentlich machen wollte.
Hier.
Mac.
Jetzt kann ich das hier machen.
220.
Äh, nicht wirklich.
So, jetzt kann ich sagen, Mac-Adress.
Sage, schwere Geburt, äh.
Stimmt.
wahrscheinlich mag das dann nicht bekommt irgendwas falsches raus
schau mal was rauskommt
Okay das sieht aber schon besser aus das sieht schon besser aus jetzt haben wir die zahlen als int
Wahrscheinlich will ich wirklich use fmt lib
Aha!
Zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, bam!
Eats!
Easy.
Ja?
Ah.
Ha!
Da sind wir, Leute.
Der Zeilenumbruch ist ein bisschen fake.
Guck mal, aber der QR-Code ist doch jetzt hier unten.
Kann ich jetzt den Line-Break wegmachen?
Ich mache jetzt den Line-Break weg und dann müsste es eigentlich passen.
Und dann reicht es mir mit C++ für heute.
Boah.
Boah, Geiss.
Jawoll.
So sieht es aus, Leute.
Beste.
Es funzt.
Was trinken hier?
Sehr nice.
Jetzt sieht der QR-Code auch gut aus, schwarz-weiß.
Dass da so ein paar blaue Punkte drauf sind, das liegt an der Kamera.
Guck, wenn man jetzt mal hier das...
Flash mal aus.
ja das sieht es natürlich kacke aus aber ich glaube ich sehe jetzt besser dass
das wirklich schwarz weiß ist das ist das ist nur wegen dem wegen dem licht
aber es sieht halt richtig unscharf und milchig aus ohne licht deswegen habe ich
bisschen lichter
so sieht man wenn man eine brille braucht du meinst so hier zum so so so
unscharf milchig aber ich hoffe dass man mit brille nicht auf einmal anfängt
blaue punkte hier drinnen zu sehen die gar nicht da sind
Aber das Textrendering,
Leute, ich guck grad so mal
von oben drauf.
Der QR-Code sieht richtig gut
und richtig scharf aus und das Textrendering auch.
Das ist wirklich gut.
Handy konnte es erkennen. Nice.
Ja, haben wir schon ausprobiert.
Excellent.
Chat.
Ich gehe jetzt auf.
Mir reicht es mit C++.
Schön, dass ihr wieder am Start wart.
Haben wir wieder was gelernt.
Wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut. Bis dann.
See you.